hey youtubers it's Charlie since we've
all had some time to process the
midseason finale of arrow I thought it
was time to do a top 10 moments from the
season so far
I'll also be doing a predictions video
next week for the second half of season
2 be sure to subscribe to get it so
let's just dive right in top 10 moments
number 10 brother blood builds an army
so most recently brother blood has been
a Teen Titans villain so I was really
surprised that arrow decided to use him
as their medium bad this season
Kevin Alejandro the actor playing
brother blood hasn't really won me over
with his performance yet but I was
really happy that they reached into DC's
bag of villains rather than create
someone totally new I'm really looking
forward to his Super Soldier army mostly
because of the consequences number 9 the
Suicide Squad who do you call when you
don't want to risk the life of a
superhero you call the bad guys
so what Diggle set Deadshot free it
actually cleared the path for Amanda
Waller to compel him or blackmail him
into the Suicide Squad they'll make an
appearance in part 2 of the season
whatever it comes back next year mostly
in response to brother Bloods new super
soldier army then I can include everyone
on the show but the current roster in
the comic books also includes Captain
Boomerang cheetah James Gordon jr. King
shark Harley Quinn the Unknown Soldier
black spider El Diablo voltaic and yo-yo
speaking of super groups number 8 the
arrival of hive high velocities during
that same Deadshot episode where he got
set free it hasn't been referenced since
but there an evil shadow organization
formed by the Slade Wilson Deathstroke
in the comic books now that we know that
Slade is the big bat this season and it
looks like he's the head of a
corporation I think that hive will be
the way that he's funding his war
against Oliver I'm also hoping as part
of that war that Slade is behind Isabel
rochev at Queen industries remember
Slade promised to crush everything in
Oliver's life and Queen industries is
part of that number 7 Solomon Grundy and
the creation of super plot threads what
this means is that arrow has done an
amazing job at expanding its own
internal universe the arrow verse just
this season they've brought in so many
references and characters from the
comics that it feels like they could
keep the show fresh longer than
Supernatural and that's been on for
almost 10 years and they haven't even
gotten to Superman Batman or the Justice
League yet
number six the League of Assassins
descends on Starling city a lot of
people were confused by this because
during the Dark Knight franchise the
League of Assassins was called the
League of Shadows they're the same thing
arrows just calling them something
different their arrival on the show
raised the stakes for Oliver to a whole
new level I was a little disappointed to
see how easily Sara killed al owal but I
feel like that was just to make us feel
safe until they returned in full force
there's actually a few surprises that
they're going to be bringing to Starling
city in the future namely Nyssa al Ghul
who's debuting in the second half of the
season she's the daughter of Ra's al
Ghul a lot of people are hoping for a
Ra's al Ghul cameo but it's unlikely
that a character that big would be on a
show this soon before introducing a lot
more medium characters but arrow takes
so many chances don't be surprised if he
has a brief cameo in the finale number 5
Roy has superpowers talk about left
turns for a character in the comic books
Roy eventually becomes red arrow and now
TV Roy has powers which is obviously the
counterweight to all the brother Bloods
super soldiers I have to wait to see him
in action before I pass judgment on
super Roy but I love how fast the show's
developing characters that will end up
becoming superheroes anyway number 4
Malcolm Merlyn is still alive I was so
happy when it turned out that John
Barrowman was back on the show and not
as a ghost he's full-on alive and just
as dangerous as ever I feel like Kevin
Alejandro is not able to bring his
villain brother bullet up to the same
level as John Barrowman was able to
bring Malcolm Merlyn up to during season
1 number 3 Sara Lance's the canary the
comic book version of Black Canary and
Green Arrow have been so intertwined in
the past that seeing her on the show was
worth the highest of fives her fight
scenes have been amazing but I'm not a
huge fan of the Sara Lance the public
face of her character she'll be back in
the second half of the season with the
League of Assassins and Malcolm Merlyn
all those plots are tied together
number 2 Slade is the big bad one of the
things I think arrow does best is pay
off big plot lines in a timely manner
using Slade as the big bad this season
ties up so many plot threads from the
island as well as last season that even
when Slade escapes at the end of this
season I won't feel cheated just to be
clear I'm pretty sure that they will not
kill Slade at the end of this season
he's too big of a character and Manu
Bennett is too amazing of an actor to
get rid of him I also said some of the
same things during my review of the
mid-season finale but the thing that
makes Slade's so exciting
a true villain is how personal his
relationship with Oliver is it's like
he's Oliver Joker he's unpredictable
he's out of his mind and he's almost
invincible
and number one the flash hands-down
favorite moment of the season so far
watching Barry Allen on screen was pure
joy it was all about watching a
superhero fanboy become a superhero
they're still working on the pilot for
the spin-off so the series hasn't been
officially greenlit but a lot of you
have been asking me if he's going to
come back on arrow originally episode 20
was supposed to be the backdoor pilot
for the spin-off but now that they've
rewritten that Grant Gustin might just
be doing another cameo like he did
during the mid-season finale so many
awesome things happening this season let
me know if your favorite is and which
are most excited to see whenever the
show comes back next year I know you're
all holding out for a Ra's al Ghul cameo
since we're heading into the holidays I
have a bunch of more bonus videos that
I'll be posting this week for the shows
that would normally be on be sure to
subscribe to get them all you can click
here to get my review of the mid-season
finale and you can click here to learn
all about a brand new show I'm going to
be doing in January called kill list
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tomorrow
high fives
you